so for those just joining
the way this is gonna work is i start a
puzzle racer
and i'll be giving progressively more
handicap every puzzle eraser i finish in
first place
the next one i'll start with five last
seconds
ten nine eight
seven okay so these are the potential
four
opponents two oh let me switch the scene
again
okay so i guess i'll give i'll start by
giving five second handicap
and i really just want to get for like
get in
good form make sure i'm not mouse
slipping or blundering anything
seeing the board clearly
it should really take like a little bit
extra time if i
i'm not entirely sure of the move
hmm almost mouse slipped there
might be on pace for a hundred
no that wasn't er
hey 103. let's go that's my first 100
plus
on stream let's go
okay that was nice
this is actually what i got earlier off
stream so nice to
actually have proof so every every new
race i'll make a new link
and again every every race i'm
progressively
taking more time off my
off my clock so this next one i'll start
with
80 seconds so 10 second handicap
five four three two hello and good luck
zero okay
so this is a the new
new race i'll start in three more
seconds
also hello ptp thanks for subbing
it's a really bad habit to like look at
the racers but i think i'm already
oh there's there's one person ahead of
me
just have to find the rhythm
no that was a mouse loop
and i can see oh the queen takes a rook
yeah there's a whole strategy to using
the skip
[Music]
button
okay got to 90 not too bad
okay so we we move on
uh yeah the um math was
wasn't first for a little bit there
oh sorry i shared the wrong link my bad
that's the wrong link i just shared the
right link
okay seven trick some people there
five four three two i was wondering why
no one was joining
zero oh wait okay wait um 15 seconds
this time
so at 1 15 so who's the competition
man anymore or delonging
okay
mm-hmm
am i safe i'm safe yeah okay
i'll just try and max out my score g5
mate let's go
i've hung me in one there basically
[Music]
okay got to 80 82
okay so this next one will be 20 seconds
so 20 seconds i'll start at 110 this
time one
zero so as long as i keep winning i keep
giving more and more handicap
so it'll be interesting if i can get
down to like 30 seconds
timaru oh team is very strong oh
okay i have to stay really focused
okay
what's this
um
that's close
whoa let's go oh that's so nice
69 to 68. i barely got that last move in
two
wow good fight team aru yeah team aru
rated
like 20 24 15 bullets
okay that was really nice
okay so that was 20 seconds
this next one will be 25 seconds
okay that's nerve-wracking
yeah though it's like very important
towards the end that you use your skip
um just so you got like some easy points
okay i'm gonna create a new one
so 25 so this will be one minute and
five seconds
when i'll start seven six five
okay here's the competition
i can kind of just watch the the initial
run
so arrow is the first to move
some people a little slow to move
so hair arrow and hyper complex
okay i know the the first two moves
oh yeah irene you do have to be quick um
maybe later we'll do we'll do a more
exclusive race oh wait i started
i forgot to start okay i'm giving more
odds than
initially planned
good afternoon oh good afternoon
thanks for being here
no what's this oh bishop h6 probably
knight g5 there but
i was lazy
was this
no no
okay 53.
let's go okay i think i started around
one minute there
i meant to start at 105. do you have any
high caffeine tea recommendations for
someone who only drinks energy
oh drinks yeah this this is this should
be on my amazon
tea link if you use a tea command some
high calf it's toasted coconut
it has more caffeine than coffee that's
uh
the caffeine content like the blue the
blue bar
um i don't drink this too often but
when i need to pick me up oh
oh it's orange car in the chat the the
creator of wechats i know he's been
coding a lot of a lot of the features of
puzzle racer
so the negative effect of playing a
wrong move
is that the puzzles get progressively
harder which i think i was aware of
yeah um and then there's a whole
if we go
we go here there's a whole explanation
of the scoring
so basically if you have a 30 move
streak
then you'll get plus four for every 10
moves
which can definitely add up so i think
that's why
like that should incentivize people to
like not guess every time
uh but yeah shout out shout out to
ornikar who's been streaming a lot of
coding sessions okay so this next one
i'm giving a 30 second handicap nine
eight seven oh team is back
five four oh team is probably gonna
surpass me zero i'm gonna need to
perform really well here um
i'm letting letting 30 seconds pass
okay so these are the first two moves
my high score is 103. i got it earlier
on stream and i got it off stream
earlier too
uh oh maxum million oh there's there's a
few quick people
okay
so again anyone who passes me i'll i'll
end up playing
no that was a mouse loop
hmm
70 let's go okay got to 70.
let's go
oh i wasn't looking at the the race like
it's
with with that time handicap i can just
just have to focus on the puzzles
okay oh stop using the engine in your
racing car
yeah all the racing cars have engines
but
it's not the stockfish type of engine
[Music]
okay let's move on let's uh let's keep
it going
so this next one i'll be giving 55
seconds
ten nine eight oh irene
irene shared a link to five four
oh actually that would be that would be
fine if irene shares the next link
but um
yeah people want to race against irene i
guess uh
the other link is in the chat
anyway okay it was a competition
oh dr boomkinstein a strong player
from india okay so ten more seconds
so this was made in two whoa it's a rain
it's fascinators
thanks for the raid okay i'm giving
handicap here
okay a lot of catching up to do
78 let's go okay i sometimes struggle to
get 78
even with full time man
was informed there it's nice being more
pressured i guess
and it's going to get more difficult
that's 55 next one will be 50 seconds
to comments about resizing the board to
see everything oh really oh
oh is there the little draggy thing oh
red
reduce the board size oh
that's actually useful comments that's
what i wanted to do but when
when you when you say it like that
there's um
there's this oh yeah this is actually
nice
i think people will probably prefer even
if the board's smaller
it'll be nice to like see everything
six five four three
okay so now we see all of the the
competition
um so i'm giving
40 second handicap
okay oh there's actually it's kind of
close wait i have to get used to the
smaller board size
wait okay 50 i start moving
i might be less accurate with the
smaller pieces
the same time my mouse has to travel
less
let's go
who be me nightcock
and droonie well played
i was close
i was really close now i'll probably
i'll probably like go back to doing sub
challenges but um
okay that was fun